[Music]
waiting
to confirm
people can see
me and hear me
as i paint
my nails
[Music]
hey
looks like it's working
hey folks how am i
i am all right it's
you know
the answer to that used to be uh i'm
okay
grading on the curve for covid and i was
just i'm okay grading on the curve for
um the world
uh plus covid you know won't go away so
that's that's in the mix but it's no
longer the only thing
ah
anyways
hope folks are doing well
just keep singing oh
thank you carowind
uh
no i don't have covid ms ms wicked wolf
i'm saying grady on the curve of
covid being a thing
ah
well
hope people are doing all right
um
and yeah i'm trying to
have a nice
chill livestream this time i'm sure at
some point topics will come up that will
make me
grant on
something or other
um
did archie get through his first
fireworks all right actually he didn't
seem bothered at all although it
probably helps that didn't really seem
like anybody like local
set off much of anything
i think he slept through most of what
happened
so yeah he was fine
um
i i see folks are going off on lea
michelle i have no investment because i
have not kept up on
any of that nonsense
and i don't intend to
i keep up on
more stuff than i would actually care to
as is i don't need to add someone from a
show i never watched
it's the neverending story in a bad way
yeah that's
that sounds about right my dog sits on
the stairs and watches fireworks oh
that's cute
the
huh
so back when i was still with
my uh my kiddo's mother we had a bulldog
who was so scared
of the fireworks she used to get into
the bathtub and you need to realize this
dog
hated the bathtub
um
so
yeah like first time she ever had a bat
a bath she screamed bloody murder
so
[Music]
well that's weird
sorry the freaking youtube streaming
thing is
shouting at me telling me that i should
insert an ad like
son of a i just barely started
streaming
if i was gonna do that at all
i wouldn't do it this soon into things
i was listening to your podcast
yesterday you said you had an english
bulldog yeah yeah that was uh that was
bridget we had full-bore fireworks for
at least three days that's
that's not fun
that's annoying is what that is
have i caught up on owl house i have and
i've shot the review
and i need to edit it um
i'm i'm trying
very hard to get caught up on other
stuff
um
or get ahead because i'm trying to take
some days to go see a friend of mine uh
who i haven't seen in a very
very long time and trying to not fall
behind but that means i have to get
ahead
uh which means that when i get back i'll
then be behind because whatever ahead i
got will be gone and
thus is the cycle of uh my working life
uh how's life treating me i'm not doing
great i got covered oh i'm sorry to hear
that logan
don't worry i got vaccine beforehand um
so whilst i'm not 100 i'm doing okay oh
well good at least
sorry give me a second here
there we go
uh
what am i caught up on well i've i have
shot reviews
that have not gone live yet for
amphibia
uh i keep it in the age of wonderbeast
owl house probably some other stuff that
i'm forgetting
uh
would i rate steven moffat's time as
doctor who show runner out of 10 nothing
i don't do the out of ten i really don't
and
at this point
a main reason that i don't do it is
um
the main reason i don't do it is that
people are gonna like record it
and
like compare or later and be like oh
oh they said this is better than this
look they gave this a higher number
rating when like i don't give a crap
like my opinions on things change giving
anything a score out of 10 people treat
it like it's immutable and i don't like
it
am i gonna watch the new matilda movies
coming to netflix in december probably
not
i've known nostalgia for matilda i
didn't read the book i didn't watch the
movie i haven't seen the play i'm sure
he's fine i've got nothing against
matilda but i have no investment in that
all right
ah
got thai food and some of the
veggies tend to get stuck in my teeth
ah
that bugs me there we go
ah
hope you're doing well out of interest
you watch only murders in the building
on hulu i don't because i don't have
hulu i don't have hulu i don't have um
apple tv
there's a bunch of stuff i don't have
oh tracy thank you very much for the
super chat first time catching a live
stream in a while saying hi and thanks
for all you do thank you tracy thank you
for making oh
that probably is worth mentioning um if
you are new here i'm gonna adjust the
camera a little bit
if you are new uh to the stream
um while i do try and keep up with chat
the only thing that guarantees that i
will see your comment and or question
will be to do it as a super chat which
will also get you a heart from me
um either that or
if you were um
a supporter on the council geeks patreon
there is also a discord where you can
post questions but those had to be in
before the start of the stream
so that's a new rule i'm implementing
because uh otherwise it'd kind of taken
over things a little bit
is thai food my favorite i don't
you stop asking like for definitive what
is your favorite is this your best is
this your top five i like it it's a
thing that i like i don't
ah like it i i i understand that like
you're asking because it's like for you
it's like fun question but for me that's
like i feel like somebody's cataloging
my life
favorites are this this this and this
and yeah
it's not a good feeling
well you're aware are you are there no
fish in your aquarium i can't remember
what the response to that was
uh
you can sing bridget the british bulldog
to the tune of rudolph the red-nosed
reindeer
[Laughter]
yeah that does fit actually
uh supreme omega thank you so much for
the super chat on the mcu do you feel
they are not good at doing grounded
street level serialized storytelling um
as seen with all the criticisms of ms
marvel and moon knight i think they have
not actually tried to do that
i think they could have tried to do that
with moon knight and definitely with ms
marvel
but i don't think they actually tried
so
i'm not gonna say they're not good at it
i will say they haven't actually done a
concerted effort of trying to do it
that's my verdict on that right now john
vinyls thank you very much if you don't
mind me asking how does bella stack up
to the really great classic disney
villains like maleficent ursula or scar
or xanatose for that matter
um
with all respect
he doesn't
not not not for me i like bellows he's a
good solid villain but he's not an
all-time classic
for me like he's good i like him he
works for the show absolutely he's not a
problem he's not a weak point he's the
strength of the show but
that tier
no
no he's he's just not
um not even zanato zana zanatos
zanatos needs to be in the conversation
for great television forget just cartoon
great long-running television villains
xanatos should be in the conversation
he's not as much as he should be
excuse me
i was five minutes later you're going to
be super strict about this i'll decide
when i look at it
all
right uh did you watch the new mini
series baymax on disney plus i haven't
because i haven't had time
don't have time for a lot
lately
uh
when you realize collector is a cheap
knockoff of bill cipher the collector
didn't do much for me i like bellas
better than the the collector is fine
what's creepy to me about the collector
is the
um
child demeanor
because the idea of omnipotently
powerful beings with the mentalities of
children
terrify me
because i have a child and i've been
around children and the idea of them
wielding that much power is
frightening
in a way that i think does work
but
that said the collector feels
i honestly
watching the last
stretch of uh episodes on
owl house when the collector showed up
again i was like oh right i forgot about
you
which probably isn't a great sign
so interesting fact about the original
final fantasy vii english dub cast
um bo billingsly voiced barrett and
sephiroth was voiced by lance bass
and george newbern no i'm not kidding i
didn't know about lance bass because he
was doing sephiroth for
kingdom hearts
so i did know about that i knew about
that
ah
strom dynasty
russell t is so wholesome and
imaginative he's he's
he has a very lovely vibe to him
whenever he does uh interviews or
there's clips of him
mcu fans are already calling for taika
to make a director's cut of thor for
because it's been leaked that they
filled many film many scenes that were
cut he could have explained so much more
what
okay
there's nothing wrong with love and
thunder
like i'm starting to get like i'm
starting to really dig in my heels
uh on this loving thunder was great
i liked it
a lot
and
the idea that like oh
to me the things that people don't like
about it or at least the ones i've seen
cited all have to do with the balance of
elements or they feel it's too goofy or
they feel that the
it clashed when it got more serious or
whatever
i didn't see anybody's complaints where
they said
they i didn't understand it or stuff was
underexplained so
while i'm sure i i'll be i would be
interested to see those deleted scenes
like in isolation out of morbid
curiosity
i didn't see any of the many complaints
i see people throughout about that movie
be about how it didn't make sense and we
needed more stuff
so
what
whatever
besides the fact that to my
understanding that what was relief
basically is a director's cut
because i remember i
only skimmed it granted but i remember
glancing over a um
an article where tycha basically said
i'm not doing a director's cut because
i'm happy with what's in the theater
so
what kind of shirt am i wearing it's
just
a bit of
fantasy queerness
how is my child by the way she's doing
all right she's doing all right
getting through the summer
will it just make sad puppy noises oh
that's right
wasn't there an old twilight zone
episode about an all-powerful child yes
there was and it was
very scary
don't spoil the film i'm not gonna spoil
the film i'm not gonna spoil
uh thor love and thunder it's very fresh
but like i love it
i think it's great
um
bookworm of the fandoms have you seen
inside by bo burnham the outtakes
they've been posting youtube in my
opinion they're such fun
i have not i haven't been
like
they might well be
you know more lighter material but
knowing how heavy
inside got i haven't really been in the
head space where it
seemed like a good idea
to uh
to take in
more of inside than i already have um
that and i tend to forget about it like
i remember hearing about it and i
checked it i'm like oh cool i should i
should look into
that and then just forgetting about it
and then i remember and then i'm like
i'm not in the mood then i forget about
it so
that's what happened to me with a lot of
stuff lately i keep forgetting that uh
westworld has new episodes out
and then i go on hbo max to watch you
know some doom patrol and it's going hey
westworld um and
i honestly i don't think oh i should
watch the new episodes of season four i
think i should re-watch season two
and then i watch doom patrol
uh
about love and thunder i haven't seen it
how did they handle jane foster and her
reason for being thor
i thought it worked just fine
i mean like i'm also somebody who never
got their uh
their nethers in a twist
over that in the first place so i know
some people like have
some very um
let's go with pointed uh hang ups about
that as a concept and some of the ways
it was done i was never one of those
people so
to me it seemed fine but understand
that's coming from somebody who never
had an issue with how it was done in the
comics either
somebody said in your comments that your
review of uh
love and fun that you're in your review
that oh yeah
uh
played by
hemsworth's actual daughter yep
yep that was i didn't realize that um
so
that was uh yeah that was a cool thing
to realize another thing that was that's
fun about love and thunder it's not a
spoiler don't worry um
is that there's these sort of shadow
demons that are like the minions of the
villain of uh gore the god butcher and
they're they're they're weird and
they're tentatively and they're all
differently designed uh and they were
designed by kids
like uh the director and the producer
and the stars like they had their kids
design monsters that scared them and
that's what they used as the basis for
these things and like that was just cool
uh strum dynasty thank you once more
super chat how likely is a marvel dc
crossover to you
[Laughter]
no
that's never gonna happen
the only way
the only way that was ever gonna happen
is if they were in comparable positions
but marvel is far outpacing dc
um at this point
marvel would have nothing to gain and dc
fans would cry foul like nobody would
have anything you need to realize that
by and large when those crossovers
happened
um
[Music]
in in
comics it was often during points where
either both companies were doing well or
both companies were doing poorly
so
yeah no that's never going to happen
especially considering that like it's
not even about just marvel or dc it's
about parent companies
it's about warner brothers and
it's about warner brothers discovery and
disney like no
no
supreme omega member for three months
much appreciated
um which bad spider-man story is worse
clone saga
or one more
day um
see here's okay
in terms of
impact in terms of what the story is
and what it did
one more day is worse
however
if you were going to tell me you have to
read one of these i would read one more
day first because it is a fraction of
the convoluted bloated length that the
clone side is the clone saga
honestly its biggest problem is its
bloated length
um
and it the sp a lot of the specifics
that go on in it are like
whatever it's just dragged on and goes
on for
ever
that's it that's the problem with that
one more than anything
ah
well that's spoiling those for those who
haven't seen the film do you think
anyone who is currently in the location
in the post-credits scene will show up
properly in other realms yeah possibly
yeah don't see why not
um
i don't expect any of those to make like
a full proper return
and like um integration in
to the main um
continuity
but
hey we could get nods we can get tiny
things here and there
hoover and roger rabbit had crossover
with some of the warner brothers
cartoons yeah that was because of steven
spielberg
the fact that he was
um
a producing force behind that was really
what bridged the gap because disney and
warner brothers weren't gonna work
together otherwise
rusty ralston thank you very much for
the super chat i'm just tired of
superhero movies in general good thing
i'm studying for a film production
degree
yes i'm sure that
that uh superhero films will stop any
minute so getting into film production
you definitely won't have to deal with
super hmm
jon vinyls thank you once more does
bello suffer from being a little too
similar to characters like horde prime
i.e colonial imperius supervillain who's
an obvious metaphor for evangelical
fundamental christianity
um
i don't think bella suffers from being
similar to being horde prime he does
suffer by the comparison though because
horde prime
is written in a way that what you choose
to have him mean
it can be a little bit subjective
because honestly
um
colonial imperialism or evangelical
fundamental christianity were not any
part of my readings on horde prime war
prime is just the world's ultimate
gaslighter
was
my thing for him and how i connected my
you know hatred of this villain because
you know he's the kind of villain you
should hate that's how i got there i
think bellows suffers from being much
more clearly
that
in specific as opposed to something that
could be that but has a little bit more
wiggle room to be something else if
you connect in other ways honestly that
might be part of the thing because since
part of his
deal is a sort of um religious
puritanism
that's
that's something that i understand but
like
speaking of someone who doesn't have
religious trauma when that comes up
with villains or like with what's her
face in the mist um you know just starts
it and they kind of
become a
an embodiment of the worst aspects of
religion i get it intellectually but i
have no emotional connection to it i
also get why those kinds of villains hit
really hard for other people
they just don't for me
um
similarly liz just finished watching
midnight mass which i still haven't seen
um but she said it was her least
favorite of the uh
of the horror series that that
guy has done his name is now escaping me
um and i asked her like do you think
it's partially because you don't have
religious trauma and it's based rather
heavily around that she went yeah maybe
um
do you still keep up with the comics
nowadays no i haven't kept up with
comics since the mid 90s like i keep up
with comics the same way i keep up with
video games i keep up with what's going
on in the broad strokes but i don't
actively participate
do you think the mcu is getting too much
hate right now i love
both
doctor strange too love and thunder and
don't understand the hate i
i think that right now the mcu
um
[Music]
is
on the other side of a peak not
necessarily the peak
but end game was a peak
and
we're on the downside from a peak
and maybe it'll pick up again but you
know when you're in the lull everybody
complains that's just kind of the nature
of what happens with long-form
storytelling if you go on long enough
not you can't be the peak every time so
when you're in a lull between peaks yeah
everybody [ __ ]
spielberg was driving force behind who
framed roger rabbit he was the driving
producing force
because it was uh it was amblin i'm
pretty sure i know he wasn't i know he
was involved in like he was the one
because disney and warner bros wouldn't
talk to each other but spielberg was
like the go-between
getting everybody on board
so primo mega thank you once again uh is
all of the clone saga bad because i feel
there are good stories and letting
without letting out may die peter and mj
becoming parents
ben taking on the mantle there are good
elements within the clone saga but as a
whole it's just such a bloated
mess
it's not superheroes for me it's the
endless stories i saw an article about
people being annoyed everything
everywhere won't get a sequel when it
was a complete story already i am with
you on that like
some some stories are designed in a way
to
um
you know to deliberately continue and
some like no that's the story
could you do more yeah but like that's
the story
we're done
and i
i respect that
probably because i do it's one of the
i've brought this up in a while but it's
one of the things that's interesting
because it's come up now in multiple
reviews of my novel
um people saying
often is kind of a light criticism
that
and and
it's said with such conviction that it's
very clear that my book is a set up for
a later work
and it's not
it's not
it is just deliberately a smaller story
but it is a finnish story that is the
story i was intending to tell i'll write
more stuff in that world i'm sure but i
don't have plans for direct follow-up
for those characters
i told the story i wanted to tell
could i tell more yeah am i planning to
no
john vinyls once again thank you so much
also as someone who's only seen clips of
gargoyles the love for xanato seems to
not just be because of childhood
nostalgia but because he was a
legitimately well-written character
xanatos
is a
wonderfully
written character what i love about
xanatos
is he is
he always has a plan
but more than that he's the kind of guy
who even when his plan doesn't work
he'll still find a way to turn it to his
advantage and not like in an omnipotent
i'm pulling all the strings type but
just like
he's just able to look at a situation
and go oh this isn't what i wanted
i could do something with that though
and he's just so good at it
and i remember i remember even as a kid
first episode of gargoyles
one of the first lines he had i was
immediately in love with him you need to
you need to realize this was early 90s
this was early 90s this line happened
and
without getting into the full context of
this he's you know he's got workers
doing some stuff and his assistant owen
who i also love um his assistant owen is
like you know some people don't want to
do this work they say this place is is
cursed and xanatos says you know my
answer to that owen
pay a man enough money and he'll walk
barefoot into hell
i just remember being bowled over
at like 10 years old
seeing a cartoon where
where a character said hell it's not
like i never heard the word before
my mother let me watch r-rated movies
select not any r-rated movie like she
curated but i'd seen r-rated movies by
that i'd heard hell
but not from a cartoon
oh he's so good
he's so good he's such a good villain
he's great
hmm
please review midnight mass i have no
immediate point mike flanagan thank you
storm dynasty i have no immediate plans
to get to midnight mass
um i have way too like again i have so
much crap i need to get to do you think
the owl house was cut short because of
homophobia if yes do you think that from
the beginning or only after the florida
stuff came out i personally not sure
what to think uh well okay well as far
as a timeline goes
owl house had already been cancelled
like in terms of it wasn't getting a
third season was gonna get a couple of
specials to wrap up the story that was
already settled before the florida stuff
came out so
one was not in a response to the other
um they're unconnected the only thing
that's connected is dana terrance who's
the creator of the owl house was
livid
about all that and was
very clear in her criticisms especially
bob chapeck uh the head of disney
do i think it was cut short because of
homophobia
no
asterisks so i don't think that whatever
person or
body
decision-making body
within disney
that made the call to not continue owl
house for more seasons more full proper
seasons i don't think they went the show
is too gay
no
i don't believe that
however
i would be very
surprised
if the fact that it's an openly gay show
was not in the mix and in the
conversation
for reasons why it was cut short
because you know it could have been
things like you know we're not getting a
lot of merchandise off this it's
honestly it's it's a little
possibly too dark and
and creepy or you know we we only see
you know we're not sure we see it
growing any bigger than it already is
and if we're gonna sink money for a
third and we wanted to get bigger we
think we've already maxed out the
audience
and somewhere in the mix of stuff like
that was probably plus you know it's
pretty gay and that makes it harder to
market
now
you know
does that mean that homophobia killed
the show
no
but it does kind of mean that
if
it wasn't uninvolved would be my belief
uh
the snap is just something i can't see
it recovering from of the mcu uh similar
to how dr who has to ignore insert the
last thing the daleks did to carry on
um
i mean it's it's just tough when you go
to a certain
when you escalate to a certain degree
eventually you just have to pull it back
and things feel smaller that's actually
part of what i talk about in the video
coming out on saturday which will be up
for early access for patreon supporters
later this evening
by the way when i say production i mean
script writing oh
well best of luck in that field
and also thank you for the super chat
rusty
between disney and warner brothers who
has the high ground
uh like it is
over annika and i have the high ground
um
depends on what
we're basing that assessment on if
you're talking about like stability
disney has warner brothers absolutely
creamed
right now
so
it really depends on what you're using
as a measure
it's over warner brothers i have the
high ground
you underestimate my power
you always have to sound slightly
constipated if you're doing angry anakin
did you ever get into anime or manga if
so any favorites no
not heavily uh when it comes to anime i
am more into anime films than shows
partly because it's a
lower commitment and also partially
because
um the tropes and visual trappings of
anime that i don't like are far more
common in the shows than they are in the
movies
um that said um
i think my favorite anime series is
still escaflone
um
manga i didn't read a lot of um
because
well partly
because
um
i i hate
i hate that they're printed
backwards
i actually i i really get a
this really bugs the hell out of me so
i'm going to go off on a tangent for a
hot minute here
so
i read a little bit of manga
early 2000s when it started breaking
through and at that point in time
they would flip
the
uh
the pictures and the dialogue so that it
could be read properly in english left
to right because japanese is read right
to left now
since then
the thing that has become not only in
fashion but seems to have been demanded
by all the weeaboos out there is that
even in english you print it
right to be read right to left
which is really
really
stupid
because i'm sorry
mirroring it
does not do anything
to disrupt the intended reading
experience
however the fact that yes you can look
at the images from right to left but you
still have to read the dialogue from
left to right means that you're actually
jarringly doing it in a mixed format
because you should in theory be opening
up reading it right to left you start on
the right you just work your way over or
you know down you know over panels or
whatever but now because it's in english
you turn the page
but you still have to start on the left
side of the page to get the dialogue to
read it this way but then the panels are
going that way no
it's stupid
just
print it
mirrored so that it makes
sense
because the only way to properly
you know retain the whole thing was if
you could also read english right to
left but you can't
i'm sorry i really hate that it's really
stupid
it's really dumb
i understand keeping it that way for an
in japanese reprint in an american
market fine
but if you're already making the
accommodation to translate to english
flip the damn thing
huh
ah
there we go
oh hey meg
uh good to see you
um
which video am i most proud of i don't
know if i have a single one
but um
some of my um
some of the ones that have been more in
depth which al also have not done well
enough for me to keep doing that format
but things like uh the one i did on the
watchman movie or uh the one on
ghostbusters2 i'm really proud of those
um or the last time i the last time i
did 90s comics free trial i'm quite
proud of that these are things that like
a lot of work went into and
um i was really
uh happy with the end result they didn't
do very well but you know
let's see let me catch up here
so do you appreciate that about the
culture series it's no overarching story
and the characters change every book
it's just the setting that's consistent
i i think that does work and like it's
honestly one of the things that i've
appreciated about at least so far the
discworld books that i've read um
because even with the few recurring
characters i've run into i like that the
stories are very self-contained
do i like scooby-doo i
don't really care about scooby-doo
uh one way or the other
uh
let's see
who's my favorite dindy disney princess
uh leia
that's kind of cheating um so let the
proper disney princess
um
i'm actually not sure like
my nostalgic favorite disney princess
movie is little mermaid i don't know if
i'd call ariel my favorite though
i mean as a character
mulan maybe maybe
i like vanellope a lot too for being
honest
i'm not always into anime and manga but
i enjoyed the labyrinth manga and the
usual studio ghibli anime i remember
flipping through the labyrinth manga i
never read it proper
yeah studio ghibli is good stuff
question has there ever been a time
uh when you see the edge lord amnesiac
hero been done well if so where
um
i mean it should it must have been done
well at some point it wouldn't have
become
uh as prolific as it was if it wasn't
done well at least once
i'm drawing a blank though
yeah i'm drawing a total blank
so uh maybe i'll think of something
after the stream ends or i will forget
that the question was asked that's
probably more likely
does mirabelle count i don't
i wouldn't
count her but like maybe for marketing
purposes she would
i don't know it's it's tough to know
what shooter shouldn't count sometimes
um
as a what we do in the shadows fan i'm
embarrassed i didn't recognize deacon's
actor as the first god that gore kills
ah i didn't recognize him because i
don't watch that show so
uh there you go
the scoobies are apollo or pansexual
polycule i'm not taking questions thank
you i've seen the tech talks goes or i'm
not even gonna argue
right now the only anime i'm caught up
uh with this spy x family is still
behind on my hero academia and need to
finish food wars yet the long-running
ones intimidate the hell out of me
there's only a cup there's only
a handful of animes that i've seen the
full runs of i've seen escaflone i've
seen the original run of helsing um
because like it got redone as like
helsing
ultimate or something
um i've seen
um
[Music]
full metal alchemist not full metal
alchemist brotherhood just full metal
alchemist i saw the whole thing
um
and
i
think
i've seen all of ghost in the shell
standalone complex
because there was the first series there
was second gig and then there was the
movie um that they did
uh
the the name the subtitle for which
escapes me right now um i think
that might be it
yeah that might be it
yeah i haven't seen that many
start to finish
you're angry about manga than the
timeless
i just i don't understand why anyone
thinks it's a good idea that's why
uh detective disco elysium is a good
amnesiac and can be an edgelord
depending on how you play him that's
true i should get back to that game
uh what do you hope to see in an encanto
tv series is that a thing is that a
thing that's happening
i don't know about that
do you think disney should do a uh
disney prince's lineup similar to the
princesses like aladdin eric
erica eric kristoff simba i mean they
could
they won't but they could
the last book i commissioned you to read
has a recurring character and it's not
revealed it's him until the end that's
going to make no sense because you've
not read well we'll
see when i get there i am working my way
through that i'm that one's
really fascinating
we'll see if it can hold my interest all
the way through but right now its
premise on that one is really
fascinating
fun fact stephanie beatrice was in labor
with her daughter while recording
waiting on a miracle
oh
that sounds perfect my favorite is
uh keita from atlantis ooh that's a good
pick i wish i wish the movie was better
some of the characters and the visual
design
are great but like i said it wasn't
the elements of that movie deserved a
better movie to be in
uh
uh have you ever had a fabulous idea
i mean i like to think so
hmm
they're trying to get an encanto tv
series off the ground i would need to
see the premise of it
was i right about the vr stuff being
disturbing
as heck yeah yeah it's
like i'll i'll get into it um when i
when i
finish it and like do a proper review
but yes it is
it is
damn unsettling
lee's favorite disney live-action remake
i don't know because i haven't watched
most of them because i don't wanna uh
discord okay i gotta hop over to the
discord uh channel real quick address
questions that are there i will try and
get through them as quickly as possible
we've we've lost a chunk of time
to um
until the last few times this has
happened so
let's see
for patreon reviews do you just choose
the movie or show that was requested in
order or the ones that you think you
would be most interested in it's two
prong i try to do them in the order that
i get the uh commissions
however um there are often other factors
how easily can i acquire whatever the
thing is if it's not readily available
on streaming that can be a factor how
long it is
um it's not uncommon for things that i
can
watch in one sitting like a movie are
gonna get prioritized over you know
someone who has commissioned me to watch
an entire season of a tv show or read a
book which is why those things take
longer and i tend to i am more caught up
on movie reviews than the various other
kinds of reviews i've been commissioned
for
i try and do them in something vaguely
resembling the order i got them but
you know it's a mishmash
i'm going to comic con in october do you
have any recommendations for any ren
fair style stores i could order from
it yeah well okay given your pronouns
are he they
i
don't um i recently got a dress in from
holy clothing which is great but those
are primarily dresses and skirts and the
like
so for more masculine-centric i don't
have a recommendation
sorry uh have you played any of the
fallout games if so what's your overall
opinion of the series if not do you have
any interest in uh going into one of the
games i i played a little bit of the
first one
um
i think i got annoyed i forget why i
think i just got distracted and did
something else i played a um
a bit of fallout 3 i got through megaton
not too much farther than that
uh and i i then i got bored and tried
something else not and i don't say i got
bored in like oh i was bored with this
game i mean like my adhd brain said
let's do something else and then um
i tried fallout new vegas unfortunately
i tried that recently
and my motion sickness is real bad it's
gotten really really bad with first
persons with first-person games so i
just i couldn't
i i and also like i'm really bad at
navigating um those things so i found
myself lost in the town like trying to
remember where a specific building was
in the town and just turning around and
going back where i came and i just i got
sick
uh so you uh so you still have control
over dc you've already released those
characters you want to public domain uh
now what do you do creatively to write
the ship after that okay so this is kind
of following up on something that uh i
said i would do if i had the power which
was to make
um some of the oldest
dc uh characters uh put them in the
public domain the main ones being batman
and superman um
after that
the honestly uh
the main thing would be
getting rid of jeff johns
and that's not because i think jeff
johns is a bad
writer i think he's actually a really
good one but
his sensibilities and his over
gruesomeness and his
discarding of um
of legacy characters i'm like dude you
you're
so much so many self-inflicted wounds
other than that like i don't have a
major plan
honestly i probably hire my friend ryan
who has thought a lot about what he'd do
so i'd probably just hire him and hand
it over to him terry pratchett robert
heinlein and harlan ellison invite you
to dinner who do you say yes to and why
i say yes to terry pratchett because i
think he would be uh the most pleasant
person to be around harlan ellison would
probably hate me on principle and i
don't actually know that much about
heinlein
if you had the opportunity would you
have dreams of fire be a tv miniseries
or graphic novel
series
if the story
if if that book specifically was being
adapted i would rather see it as a
graphic novel
because being an actor i would nitpick
the [ __ ] out of anybody performing those
characters i would rather see it as
graphic novel
do you think the right are going to be
able to stop kids from being progressive
by teaching them propaganda in school
the right want to take control of school
curriculum so they can teach
kids a desire for equity
across race and sexuality lines is it
anti-american
social is that is an anti-american
socialist plot basically what they
taught boomer kids back in the 50s my
hope is it won't work for two reasons
they don't have broader pop culture
reinforcement of that message like they
did back then and kids even sis had
white kids today
are in a way worse position than kids 70
years ago so it's going to be harder or
impossible to convince them the
statuesque in america is fine uh line
um
i'm
so i don't i i i want to be careful i
talk about this
certain areas are dealing with this in
very
bad ways so like obviously florida is
doing this a lot because they're they're
banning critical race theory which isn't
even taught at the grade school level
and they have the whole don't say gay
bill and all this other stuff they're
they're obviously trying
they are trying they're honestly it's
not even that they're trying to mold
young people into their mindset they're
trying to cut them off from progressive
ideas
which you kind of have to do because
more often than not more progressive
ideas tend to make more sense because
they appeal to a fundamental notion of
fairness that most young people have
and tend to assume that's how the world
works or it should
um but yeah i don't think the ability to
actually
enforce that even if they could do it
consistently across the country which
they can't um
you know
kids have too much access to outside
information
you not only have to control the
curriculum you'd have to
cut off their internet access or half
the streaming platforms like the
it's just it's self-defeating
it's infuriating but self-defeating
going off of dharma's second question
which three famous people dead a live
real or fictional would you invite to
dinner
i'm ba
i'm bad for these kinds of questions
these kind of hypotheticals
i don't know
any anybody who i invited i will
probably ultimately end up being
disappointed with having met so i don't
know if you've watched it
thoughts on season three of the orville
i only did parts of season one it wasn't
that i disliked it i just got caught up
in other stuff and never got back to it
um i've started dming for the first time
the rest of my group are new to d and d
at what point should i introduce the
standard pre-session
ritual sacrifice
but you that's usually um
you know how like certain
topics are like third date topics that's
that's a third session thing
uh so far as i know it's not being
written yet but a while back i read that
george orwell's estate had given
permission for a feminist writer to do a
version of 1984 from the perspective of
julia since i found this uh since i
found that something i've been thinking
about is if you're writing a book like
1984 but with a female protagonist
would you include the fact that
totalitarian societies tend to use
sexual assault as a way of oppressing
women uh like would including that be
gratuitous or would not including it be
dishonest and defeat the point of doing
the gender flip so
i think there's a there's a fine line to
walk on that
because i think you can i think they
they're if you're trying to do a
critique of what you think
the actual problems with a totalitarian
fascist society is then
it would be disingenuous to not at least
acknowledge that that having been said
that does not require you to actively
depict it it can be acknowledged as a
thing that exists or happens it does not
have to happen directly to the character
whose perspective we have
i think it is possible to acknowledge
that reality
without
well basically without pulling a game of
thrones uh tv show version where you
just you
you go beyond what is necessary to make
the point it just becomes gratuitous
sansa
at the moment it's not going forward
anymore but for a while there was plans
to do a culture tv series if that did
happen do you think you'd be interested
in watching it or would you only check
it out if you were commissioned or
something that
i would think about that the same way i
i tend to think about the notion of
there being a foundation series based
off asimov stuff i'm like why
it's not that it's unadaptable like you
literally couldn't but i'm like
i just don't see what about this
makes anyone think that would work as a
tv series
like especially given that with the
culture that the stories jump all over
the place that's one of the strengths of
the series i'm finding at least
hey there heat index is 108 degrees
again 42 degrees centigrade pray for me
oh goodness
uh anyway how do you feel about the
gentle minions meme and how it's causing
a lot of rowdiness in movie theaters
including throwing bananas
this one's news to me
i
i have missed out on this meme
and i think i'm probably the better for
it
uh in some of the doctor who extended
universe stuff there is a rip-off of the
culture called the people there's a
couple of differences they live in a
dyson sphere instead of orbitals
uh they only have one mind called god a
set of thousands but they're pretty much
the culture do you think it's
interesting to have them actually do you
think it would be interesting to have
them actually appear on the show i don't
know
it would depend on like how they've been
used up to this point
um because if it's just one of those
things where it basically
uh
boils down to
um
if it just basically boils down to one
series commenting on another i don't
need that
uh have you heard of amigo the devil
before i told you about him no have you
gone swimming recently uh
three weeks ago
what's your opinion on banana splits
actually never had one
never uh never felt the need
i was never interested that's it for the
discord i am back in the main chat
uh for a little bit
longer why did i try and roll an l
what are you doing
what are you doing
did i see the movie the black phone i
have not seen the black phone it's quite
a bit in the theaters that i have not uh
seen
in a bit um so no i haven't seen the
black phone i still haven't seen
everything everywhere all at once which
i really want to
when i miss things when they're new it
can take me a
while
to uh
to get back to them
how do i draw a slightly bent knee from
the front i don't know i don't draw
you said you think the doctor should be
played by a british actor but would you
be cool with an australian or a new
zealand or new zealand dick
or kiwi um
playing playing a doctor
am
i don't know i
to me just feel baked into the mentality
of the show as a whole because part of
the reason that i think the doctor
should stay
um
british is because
i for me i think it's important that
doctor who hold on to its identity as an
incredibly british property
and i'm
i'll say that i would dislike it less
than if they ever cast an american but i
wouldn't love it
did you hear about sofia miles defending
no clark depressingly yes
rowan i
did i did
the funny thing was
i heard about that
and
i had to look up who sophia miles was
i'm like i know that name but and like
i'm looking for imdb i'm like i don't
know any of this and then i got to
doctor who uh the girl in the fireplace
i'm like oh
oh
god damn it
yeah
how did you get lost in fallout new
vegas did you forget about the pip-boy
map was it a confusing map to you i
i don't remember i like i was just
trying to
it was one of those cases where like i
could find the buildings but trying to
remember which building was which
um
that's how i was getting lost and yeah i
just i got motion sick
david tennant and peter cavalli are
scottish i'm aware
that's british isles british is british
isles
yes my pronouns are he they i don't
really care what i wear dresses are fine
well then check out uh holy clothing
although
they their stuff takes a while to get in
so if you need something quickly that's
not gonna work
who's sophie miles she played renee
uh madame de pompadour controversial
question
do you think porn can be considered art
in certain forms yeah
hell yeah of course he can
absolutely
anyone suggesting that it's impossible
for that to be the case
like i don't think they understand art
sorry i'm just hearing rain all of a
sudden like it
i like like really
thick drop thick drops
ah
question what's your favorite type of
design for characters personally i like
the designs of
uh natsuya namora the man behind the
designs for a lot of square enix games
funny you mentioned square enix because
i'm incredibly
partial to yoshitaka amino
so
it's funny you mentioned square enix
um have you by chance seen the ducktales
reboot with david tennant not all of it
but most of it and it's
so much fun
it's so much fun i love it
excuse me
supreme omega
thank you so much for the super chat
comic question do you feel continuity
is important because i like when new
writers build upon what came before
instead of retconning or ignoring
previous stories
so
continuity is important
however
the problem especially for comic books
especially for long-running characters
like your
superman your batman your x-men your
spider-man
and your wonder woman
is that
at a certain point
the continuity has been going on so long
that it starts to box you into a corner
or as a writer can feel that way you
feel like like i have this story that i
think would be great for this character
but i can't tell it
because continuity of x y and z means
that this shouldn't be possible or
it or whatever else so like
continuity is great until it's not
and it's generally a
a function of time the longer it goes on
the more
difficult it can be
to come up with new things to do
that don't in some way
require a breaking of continuity or a
retconning of it
um
but
overall i think
um
continuity is a good thing and it's
better to build off it than to ignore it
that said i'm one of those people who's
kind of of the opinion that the best
approach to continuity is that
it's there
but you probably shouldn't base too many
of your stories completely off of it
so like
i really enjoyed the discworld books
that i've read so far or the culture
novels that i've read so far
which absolutely have a continuity
but also don't build directly one on the
other so they do feed into each other
insofar as my
um reading one enhances my understanding
and my appreciation of another
but it's not required reading in terms
of you won't understand what the hell's
going on that's kind of my preferred
way for things to go
with occasional dips into we're building
continuity for like this
big thing we're doing
but i kind of like
i kind of like more self-contained stuff
which
you know
it doesn't lean as hard on the
continuity stuff
have i ever been to a furry con would i
ever try it i have not
and uh
probably not if only because i would
feel very out of place i don't have a
fursona and
i think i'd just be wandering around
going
i i feel like i've crashed a party i
wasn't invited to
you know
oh see ya meg thanks for stopping in
the solution to continuity wall is the
uh idea of the multiverse everything is
canon so just enjoy it see i don't like
multiverses though
uh do you think you could rock the look
of weiss the emasculate if you don't
know who that is look him up well i'm
gonna have to
let's see
weiss
the immaculate
[Laughter]
no
oh dear god
oh
that was cleansing
yes overtime thank you carowind i'm just
gonna i'm gonna wrap up i'm gonna finish
my water and maybe address another
another question or two
have you read superman and batman
generations if so what do you think of
it i have not so i have no opinion what
kind of character would hella bonham
carter play and doctor who not a clue
don't really particularly need to see
her there have you missed watching
episode have watched black mirror are
you re-watching episodes i'm i'm only
re-watching them when liz is up for
watching another one that she hasn't
seen yet i'll watch them with her but
that's about it
uh i compared surface detail to the uss
callister in terms of how disturbing the
vr stuff was do you think that was
appropriate particularly the feeling of
being totally trapped yeah that's a fair
comparison that is a that is a fair
comparison indeed
uh you're welcome for the laugh thank
you that was much appreciated
uh
the warcraft movie was one of the best
video game
film adaptations ever i kind of figure
out why they haven't made a lich king
movie
um
i mean that's um
that's a heck of a scale to measure on
first of all
oh
that movie i did not have fun watching
that movie
i feel like they might as well have
called it lore dump the film
the other film i saw uh in the cinema
this weekend was brian and charles never
heard of that if you like robot i'm
frank i think you'd like this
and find the original short here on
youtube
i do like robot and frank
i know a lot of people here have
misgivings about edgelord heroes but i'm
always of the opinion that there's
always a reason they became as they are
so i don't get the hate you know and
for me my issue with edgelord heroes
honestly has less to do with the heroes
and more to do with the writers i feel
like
i've rarely seen edgelord heroes
deployed in a way that didn't feel like
a writer sitting behind
a keyboard and being like yeah yeah
yeah i'm edgy yeah oh this is gonna get
people mad oh i'm so edgy and
maybe that's me projecting
but like i it it always feels like it um
it gives me a bad image of the
writer
at least if they're doing it straight
because like you could argue that say
rorschach is a edgelord hero but if you
actually pay attention to watchmen
rorschach is not cool
rorschach
is awful
excuse me
i'm a furry becoming one and getting a
fursona is easy
uh what would be your top five animals
you like most then use one of those or
two or three mixed like a chimera i'm
sure i could come up with a fursona
if i was so inclined i remember asking
on tick tock on the old account
um
i remember asking
what people thought
my fursona would be and i don't remember
a lot of the answers
but
there is one in specific that i do
remember somebody like did a video
response in like this really
um
[Music]
passionate case
uh
for why i'd be a clydesdale
not just a horse but a clydesdale
specifically that stuck with me
they they they'd really thought about
that it was kind of fun
um
but anyways
i think i am going to wrap it up there
i am out of water
where now i am
ah
so
uh
oh yes uh twitch
tomorrow
um councilgeeks on twitch i'm playing uh
tomorrow and for the
foreseeable future i will be playing
spirit fairer because i'm in the mood
for something chill
and laid out and relaxed
that will also make me cry so
that's what i'm going to be doing for a
while
um definitely all this week
and uh also tomorrow i'll have a review
at some point uh in the day of the
latest episode of ms marvel over in the
break room and if you are uh a patreon
supporter
the satur saturday's video on phase 4 of
marvel will be up for early access
actually within the next
10 minutes or so um and if you aren't
already a supporter on patreon
patreon.com council of geeks you can um
get early access do that video and
others as they become available but in
any case
oh we got oh we had one more super chat
sneak in there supreme omega oh and i
missed uh s s thump ten thank you for
the for the haya
figure much appreciated um and supreme
omega on the no killing rule with
superhero genre do you feel it can be a
narrative hindrance because i feel
it uh it's only used to preserve popular
villains no i think it's only a
hindrance if literally every character
in your universe has it
for specific superheroes no i don't
think it's a hindrance at all
batman needs that role superman needs
that rule
and it's part of their core fundamental
what makes them who they are
is the choice to never kill
does that mean popular villains stick
around yeah it does but more importantly
it means that this is
their statement of no i'm not going to
take the easy way out
and kill these people so they're not a
problem again because
i won't be that person
so no i only think it's a hindrance if
you if you only think in terms of
pragmatic characters and speaking as a
pragmatic person there's nothing wrong
with characters not being pragmatic and
doing something because of the principle
of something
so there you go
anyways thank you so much uh hopefully
i'll see some of you uh tomorrow for
spirit fair it's a game i love i've
played it before and i just wanna i just
wanna chill out on a boat with my cat
do some fishing
talk to some dead people it'll be great
so um thank you all i hope that you have
a good rest of the week
and
i hope that you remember that
you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you're the council i'm just running the
meeting and until next time this council
is adjourned
my cavity